Now, one of those issues that I'll focus on today...
...is fundamental to the security of our nations and to the peace of the world.
That's the future of nuclear weapons in the 21st century.
The existence of thousands of nuclear weapons is the most dangerous legacy of the Cold War.
No nuclear war was fought between the United States and the Soviet Union,...
...but generations lived with the knowledge that their world could be erased in a single flash of light.
Cities like Prague that existed for centuries,...
...that embodied the beauty and the talent of so much of humanity,...
...would have ceased to exist.
Today, the Cold War has disappeared...
...but thousands of those weapons have not.
In a strange turn of history,...
...the threat of global nuclear war has gone down,...
...but the risk of a nuclear attack has gone up.
More nations have acquired these weapons.
Testing has continued.
Black market trade in nuclear secrets and nuclear materials abound.
The technology to build a bomb has spread.
Terrorists are determined to buy, build or steal one.
Our efforts to contain these dangers are centered on a global non-proliferation regime...
...but as more people and nations break the rules,...
...we could reach the point where the center cannot hold.
Now, understand, this matters to people everywhere.
One nuclear weapon exploded in one city,...
...be it New York or Moscow, Islamabad or Mumbai, Tokyo or Tel Aviv, Paris or Prague,...
...could kill hundreds of thousands of people.
And no matter where it happens, there is no end to what the consequences might be,...
...for our global safety, our security, our society, our economy, to our ultimate survival.